-This is the seventh time
you've played this character
And this one, you've had to wait
a long time
until people
have been able to see it.
It must be exciting
to finally have it available
-Yeah. It is.
It's kind of --
We've had so many false starts
because we were supposed
to come out May 1st of --
Wait, was it last year
or the year before?
I don't even know.
I've lost all track of time.
I think it was last year, right?
Oh, my God, what year is it?
-I know, that happens.
-Oh, thank you.
Yeah, isn't that weird?
What's so weird is
that we made it in 2019,
and then it was supposed
to come out in 2020.
But, to me, somehow 2019 seems
like it was four years ago
But it wasn't, right?
It was only two years ago?
-I like that now
your regular life
is as confusing as
the Marvel cinematic universe.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "Yes, we
got married in 2020.
But it actually happened
before the pandemic."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It's a multiverse.
My life is
part of the multiverse.
No, but, yeah. It came out
It was supposed to
come out in May 2020.
And then we were scramblin
to finish it.
You know, COVID happened,
and everything shut down.
And so that actually enabled u
to work a little bit on it
remotely, which was strange,
but we were happy to have
more time just to finish it.
And then it was supposed t
come out in November,
and then that started
to look dicey.
Anyway, it's been long.
It's been very, very long.
But now you can go
to the theater and see it!
So that's the -- That's a huge
you know, relief
and also something to celebrate,
so we're excited about that.
-It must be one of the nic
things about those Marvel movies
has been that you work with th
same people over and over again.
And you're obviously
a very tight group of people
But this is really cool, because
there is your sort of
the connection
to the existing universe,
and there's all these
great new actors,
like Florence Pugh
and Rachel Weisz.
And David Harbour --
David Harbour strikes me
as a guy who's
really fun to be around.
-Um, David Harbour is --
like, he's so campy.
You kind of don't expect it,
because it feels like
he would be kind of a big,
brooding sort of, like, grump.
He definitely
could be grumpy sometimes.
But on the --
Like, he's grumpy,
and then,
on the flip side of that,
he's, like, a song-and-dance
showman type.
He's just -- He's a wonder
He has many, many facets.
And I can't wait for them al
to be revealed in this movie
He's very funny in this movie.
And he's lovable and annoying.
And, like, you know,
he's just -- Yeah.
He plays that kind of, like,
dad figure that embarrasses yo
and says the wrong thing,
which is crazy,
because there's no possible wa
he could be my father.
He's way, way too young.
It's just crazy.
But, anyway, that's how it is in
the Marvel cinematic universe,
multiverse.
-[ Laughs ]
They're like, "Look,
there's always a --
There already is a willing
suspension of disbelief.
Let's just ride it out."
-"Let's just make up
a 42-year-old person
the father of
a 36-year-old woman."
But that's fine.
[ Laughter ]
He has a lot of gray
in his beard.
-I know you guys have sort of --
The original "Avengers" group,
you guys got some tattoos.
Is there an existing share
tattoo amongst the Avengers?
-Yes.
We have an "Avengers" tattoo
The only person
who doesn't have it is
Mark Ruffalo,
because he's lame, basically
-Yeah.
-We tried to get him to do it.
We said, "What about if we
did it in, like, white ink
What if it was, like,
we did it in water,
and we could have the experience
of all doing it together?"
He just -- It was, like, not -
He just shut it down.
It was not a thing.
He's such a party pooper!
-Yeah.
-What a big party pooper.
-It's a real Bruce Banner move
Let's be honest.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what we all said.
-It's very, very --
-That's what we all
called him out for.
-Very in character.
My last question is,
because Colin,
when he's been on the show
has often talked about
the terrible gifts
that Michael Che gets him.
Did Michael Che get you guys
a wedding gift yet?
-This whole thing between them
with the gifts
basically, it's hilarious
for them,
and then I get left with all the
giant junk I can't get rid of,
'cause, it's, like,
personalized.
And I'm not gonna throw ou
a big Michael Che --
The other day, I don't know wh
this thing came to our house
It's humongous.
It's this massive framed -
like, you know, when you go to
like, a Planet Hollywood-style
type restaurant, and there's
like, memorabilia
that they frame, like,
a giant hockey thing?
It has all
the different trophies.
It's like that, but it's a
Michael Che one for something.
I don't know what it is.
It's basically free swag
that he didn't want
in his office or his home,
and he just ships us his crap.
-Yeah.
-And then I have to figure out
what to do with it.
It's -- I hate it!
I hate both of them right now.
I'm just like, "What next?
Why am I getting your swag
I don't want any swag."
-I remember -- by the way, Colin
is also a perpetrator
of this kind of thing.
Because the first -- When my
wife and I first lived together,
we had, like, a house-warmin
party for my birthday.
And Colin brought me a card,
and when I opened the envelope
$2 worth of pennies
spilled on the floor.
-Oh, my God, that's terrible
-Because he wanted me to g
get a coffee at my corner deli
And we found pennies
for, like, a year afterwards
And Alexi was like,
"This was so funny."
[ Chuckles ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-The first thing he ever got m
was, I guess
he went on some trip, you know
he would go --
When he does stand-up,
he goes all over the place
and then he'll go to, like
these weird little antique malls
and stuff and find
haunting presents for people
And he got me a bullfrog -
like, a taxidermy bullfrog
playing, I think, like, th
banjo or something like that
and just left it when --
I guess I was in the room.
He left to go to work
or whatever.
When I came out, it was just
sitting on the floor.
-[ Laughs ]
-And with a little card
that said like, "Hi, Scarlett,
or something like that.
Just so creepy.
And then I tried
to get rid of it.
But I felt bad throwing it away,
'cause it was
the first present he got me.
And so he would just
move it around
to different parts of my house
Like, I would open up
to get a little cup of --
like, a glass for a rose,
and it would be in there,
in the drawer.
And then sometimes
I'd open up my closet
and try to pull a shirt ou
and it'd be hiding behind...
It was awful. Absolutely awful
-Well, I'm just gonna give you
a recommendation.
If Che ever gets married,
you should send it to him
as a gift.
-Yes! Oh, my God.
Full circle.
[ Both laugh ]
-Thanks so much for being here
Scarlett.
I look forward
to seeing you soon.
-Thanks, Seth. You too.
-"Black Widow" is in theater
and available on Disney+ now